the way it's working is that some states
are choosing to close like the developed
campsites and their national forests and
then others are actually keeping them
open so you really have to go forest by
forest and look to see what's going on
[Music]
everybody this is Nick De Santis from
the hustle welcome to another episode of
behind the hustle the show where we take
you behind the scenes to tell you a
little bit more about some of the
stories that were working on and I'm
really excited about today's episode
because we're here to talk about van
life and this is a trend that you may
have heard of on Instagram or on social
media people who essentially live life
from the road and we actually about a
week ago we wrote a story about this in
our daily email and it was not something
that I obviously had heard the Instagram
hashtag and has read a little bit about
this trend but didn't know a ton about
it but luckily we have a contributor who
writes for us out in San Francisco her
name is MIA Sullivan and it turns out
that she is actually planning as soon as
the shelter and place orders list to hit
the road and live a little bit of the
van life herself so I wanted to invite
her in to talk a little bit about where
the idea came from and and what she was
planning so thanks a lot Mia for joining
us I really appreciate it yeah of course
hey everyone so you know now he's kind
of feels like a strange time to choose
to move into a van but me and my fiance
planning on doing that in the summer so
we're we're hoping to still go and just
a little bit of background on how the
idea came about for us we were really
interested in taking a year off and and
traveling living a more simple life and
we're big backpackers so we thought we'd
be pretty good candidates to move into a
small space and we have a big dog who's
gonna be traveling with us so we're
designing our van
with him and kind of our our lifestyle
in mind yeah one of the things that you
had called out in the story that you
wrote for us a couple days ago was the
fact that there's sort of a wide variety
of vans and there are certain people who
sort of do a more low-tech version of it
and then there are other people who have
fans that use sort of called kind of
mini bunkers so you sent me a couple
pictures of the van that you're actually
like building out it looks like tell us
a little bit about what that looks like
yeah so it is a 2015 Mercedes Sprinter
van it is it has a 170 inch wheelbase so
it's it's one of the longer ones there's
like a shorter one than a bit of a
longer one I would say our build out is
gonna be more definitely more like the
bugger than bare-bones so we'll have
running water we'll have heat we won't
have a full bathroom but we will have a
toilet and we'll have a like an outdoor
shower situations so it will be pretty
pretty contained we won't have to rely
on gyms or you know bathrooms and in
random random town so I'm feeling pretty
good about that especially now and we
were gonna get a smaller water tank but
we're opting for the bigger 35 gallon
tank given the pandemics so how how
how's the renovation going like you sent
me some photos has it been challenging
have you run into headaches I'm curious
about sort of how what that process has
been like yeah so it's going well it is
very challenging for me my fiance is the
Builder out of the two of us so he's
been the one who is figuring out you
know like what to do and what to buy and
then I am the assistant so the other
week we cut out a window in our van
we've it's the third window that we've
installed and
he was the one who was doing all the
cutting and the planning and the
measuring but I was basically you know
helping him handing him things cleaning
so it's going well but there are certain
things coming up like the electrical
wiring that I know he's pretty nervous
about you know cutting a window into a
man is nerve-racking and I think he
handled it well so so far so good good I
mean it certainly looks it was I was
surprised at how big the man was it's
but it certainly looks like things are
going well yeah it's it's pretty big I
think that um you know with our with the
two of us and our dog it will probably
be a good size and probably won't feel
very big we have no it's just an empty
box with insulation and a few windows so
tell us a little bit about like your
your plans one of the other things that
you had written about last week was sort
of where people are allowed to go and
how there's national park land and
national forests where maybe some of
those sort of more common camping
facilities in those places are shut down
to visitors but you know there's sort of
more wide-open spaces that are very
people can go so I'm curious like what
does your route look like are there
particular landmarks or places where you
want to go yeah so um we were planning
on doing more of a we're gonna start
going up the west coast so I live in San
Francisco we are gonna go up the west
coast and hit Oregon and Washington
State however much of the land right now
is closed in Oregon and because we're
starting a month later than we wanted to
we're gonna actually skip that for now
and do that on the back end of our trip
so we're gonna head to Montana Idaho and
Montana first and hit national forests
it's pretty confusing it's not like oh
all national forests are closed right
now
um the way it's working is that some
states are choosing to close like the
developed campsites and their national
forests and then others are actually
keeping them open so you really have to
go forest by forest and look to see
what's going on what I have found is
that most national forests are open to
dispersed camping so that means you can
just drive your van somewhere on this
huge piece of land and encamped and be
alone and so that is what our trip is
going to look like especially in the
beginning you know there might be I
think that you know there are some
states that are reopening maybe they'll
be like small towns in Montana that we
can check out and just you know be
really really careful but especially in
the beginning with the pandemic still
you know kind of raging we're gonna be
in mostly like isolated we might even
stay in a knot in one National Forest
for like two weeks and then kind of
continue on and just you know hike and
and explore have you thought about if
you do run into other people on the road
how you'll handle that given all the
concerns about social distancing that
aren't gonna be going away anytime soon
yeah so we bought we bought cool masks
with with mask filters so we're
definitely gonna be wearing those yeah
we'll have gloves and you know we'll
just kind of keep our distance from
people I think that it actually we're
gonna be interacting with a lot fewer
people then we kind of happen to
interact with now just going to the
grocery store and like being in a city
so you know I'm I think that aisle if
antibody tests if and when antibody
tests are available that's up you know
obviously something that will be
interested in in doing so we can you
know feel more safe meeting people but I
think for the beginning you know it's
gonna be like masks keep our distance
but another thing
thinking about is it'll be interesting
we might go to certain places where no
one's wearing a mask you know we might
be in a small town in Montana and like
people will look at us like we're crazy
well I'm really interested in how all of
those dynamics will play out and are you
planning to document your travels in any
way I think one thing that we had talked
a little bit about is you were maybe
hoping to write some stories from the
road or I'm curious about like are you
gonna be trying to tell any stories of
people who are in who are dealing with
the pandemic and I'm curious about like
are you are you gonna try to document
this trip in any way oh yeah so yeah as
a journalist it will my aspiration is
for it to be incredibly documented so
the main thing I'm doing is is a podcast
it's called places it will launch in
June and it's gonna be about it's gonna
be stories about like small towns across
the US that was my original plan for it
and I'm already a few episodes deep just
on on the background from from kind of
how we're planning to go about the trip
however I do think that with the Krone
of our situation the focus may change a
little bit that's that's still to be
determined from my end
but yeah the podcast will also weave
through our experiences traveling on the
road so that's one yeah that's one thing
I'm doing and then yeah I would I am
planning to collect stories on the trip
and yeah want to write about like what
it's like what kind of like how people
are living in smaller towns because I
think that the view that I'm getting is
this is how people are living in cities
and I think that's a lot what's being
reported on but like how
are people approaching it in in small
towns are they afraid of it are they
like this is ridiculous so I'm really
interested in that and kind of the rural
urban divide of fear in the crisis in
maybe some places that haven't been
quite so hard as it hit as places like
San Francisco or DC where I am yeah I'm
also curious like as you talk to friends
and family about your plans are there
misconceptions that come up or things
that you where you have to sort of
people try to talk you out of it or they
have concerns that they raise I'm
curious you know what is the reaction
when you tell other people about your
plans
have they been supportive or there are
the things that you have to sort of
explain what is some of those
conversations look like yes so in like
before the pandemic I think everyone was
extremely supportive even to a point
that it really surprised me that people
are so supportive um but at the same
time I think that you know a lot of the
people I was telling know me very well
and it's the type of thing that's like
oh that makes sense that you would want
to do that maybe like they wouldn't want
to do that but it makes sense for you so
yeah I felt really lucky for people to
be supportive I think now honestly it's
surprising but no one has said oh I
think that you should postpone this trip
I don't think it's a good idea to do it
you know this year anytime soon but I
wonder if people kind of think that but
they don't want to burst our bubble but
it but some people some people have said
oh well you know we just want to make
sure you have a great experience and we
don't want you to like not be able to to
go to the places that you wanted to go
and do the things that you wanted to do
and so that I get that but the other
people say oh well that seems like the
most socially distance thing you could
do right now like live in a van just
with your you know partner and boyfriend
and Mike hiked around in places that
there
aren't people so as if you're getting on
a bunch of airplanes yeah so I don't
know I mean no one's come out and no
one's come out and said I think this is
a horrible idea yet you're like most
looking forward to
obviously circumstances are different
now but you know what's the thing that
you're most excited about so I think a
combination between like a slower pace
of life and being able to connect with
people and tell stories about places
that are foreign to me
I think the connecting with people part
is one thing I am anxious about what
that's a huge part of the trip and if we
can't like interact with that many
people I think it will be very
unfortunate but I'm optimistic that we
can figure out creative ways to still
connect cool that's really good well
thanks for taking some time to tell us
about it
obviously with you know there's the
you're still sort of waiting on the
green light I think but we're going to
be excited to to follow some of your
trip and I'm sure we'll we'll talk more
and and I think you had said the other
day that we might when the van has
finished get a little bit of a visual
tour so I'm looking forward to that as
well
yeah absolutely yeah I'd love to show
everyone around it should be done at the
end of June so well good luck with the
rest of the renovations I hope
everything goes well and I'll talk more
soon thanks Nick thanks bye everybody
[Music]
you